So this is very interesting, I teased this
earlier in the show.
Donald Trump's daughter in law, Larra Trump,
was interviewed on Fox News this week and
she was actually asked about the health concerns
surrounding Donald Trump after his completely
outrageous behavior during the West Point
commencement speech that he gave over the
weekend.
Now, I want to be like crystal clear.
What's important about this is not so much
what Larra Trump says.
Obviously, Laura Trump says Trump's fine,
right?
That's not surprising.
We wouldn't expect her to say anything other
than that.
What matters here is that the story actually
made it onto Fox News back in 2016.
In all of those bogus, Hillary Clinton has
Parkinson's type stories.
Hillary's unhealthy.
Hillary's dying stuff even now.
Stories about Joe Biden.
And we see Tucker Carlson and Sean Hannity
sort of allude to Joe Biden's cognitive state.
We have not seen any mentions of Donald Trump's
obviously odd behavior that could be related
to health.
We already discussed on the Monday show Trump
struggling to drink a glass of water and,
you know, sort of having to use his other
his left hand to to help himself drink water
at West Point.
We saw the video of Trump almost being helped
down a ramp by a military officer looking
incredibly ginger and unstable and frail,
raised a whole new host of questions about
Trump's health.
So here is Fox anchor Martha MacCallum actually
asking Lara Trump about health concerns.
Take a look at what the hubbub over this.
Well, I think it's sort of sad that nobody
focused on what the president actually said
at his address there at West Point.
It was such a message of unity and togetherness
and strength of America and how proud he was
of all of those graduates there.
Let's put all that.
Yeah.
Was so nice.
Is that people more than, of course, focus
on the way he walks down a ramp.
This was a ramp that was, you know, had no
missteps, no handrail.
The president had on leather shoes.
Of course, he's gonna take his time and go
down.
I got to farm out in front of cameras.
Now I get it.
But just to just to ask you straight out,
is there anything about the president's health
that the American public doesn't know?
No, absolutely not.
It's just fodder for for the critics are there
to attack.
So, of course, it's not surprising that Laura
Trump says everything's completely fine and
there's nothing to see here about Donald Trump's
health.
That's not really why I'm talking about this.
The point is, the fact that this was even
on Fox News is huge because it means that
the issue of Trump's health is now on the
radar of some of these right wing Trump sycophants
who primarily get their news from Fox News
and wouldn't ordinarily hear about this story.
So understand that were it not for segments
like this.
There is a huge portion of the country that
wouldn't even know anything about Donald Trump's
confused speech and limited reading ability,
visible confusion, the often dilated pupils,
while sweating his strange stance and all
of the other signs that have been topics of
concern around the country for years at this
point in time.
So I'm not really praising Fox News in any
kind of broader way.
But it's a good thing that the story actually
made it on the air, because this is likely
the first time that a ton of Trump pissed
Fox News watchers are even hearing about the
fact that there are health questions surrounding
Donald Trump.
Now, also, just kind of in the vein of fact
checking.
Remember that initially Donald Trump explained
the reason that he walked down the ramp so
slowly and gingerly was that the ramp was
slippery.
Donald Trump tweeted over the weekend, quote,
The ramp that I descended after my West Point
commencement speech was very long and steep,
had no handrail and most importantly, was
very slippery.
The last thing I was going to do was fall
for the fake news to have fun with final 10
feet.
I ran down to level ground momentum.
So that was quickly identified as bogus because
people just looked at weather reports and
video of the event.
It had been completely dry and sunny all day,
so the ramp was not slippery.
Notice that now there is a new explanation
from Larra Trump, which is that there was
no handrail and there were no steps and that
Trump was wearing leather shoes.
The no steps thing is extra funny because
by definition, ramps don't have steps.
It's like, well, he would have gone down the
ramp faster if it had steps.
Well, then it wouldn't be a ramp, would it?
It would be stairs.
So ultimately, what do we make of the ramp
incident?
I don't know.
Here's a side by side video for our television
audience of Joe Biden and Donald Trump, both
walking on ramps.
The level of mobility is clearly very different.
Does this mean anything other than Trump is
getting older?
Maybe not.
The point is, we don't know.
It could be a sign of a stroke.
It could be a sign of really anything.
We just don't know.
And importantly, none of this is anything
to make fun of.
Donald Trump is 74 years old.
He's obese.
It's not shocking that he would have some
mobility issues.
But the point is the constant dishonesty and
attacking others, never answering questions
straight up and increasingly deceptive feeling
statements and actions when it comes to his
health, which we'll talk about later, including
the completely bogus thing from 2019.
Remember where he was rushed to Walter Reed
Medical Center.
And we were told, you know what?
He just had a few free hours.
He decided to get a jump on that 20, 20 physical.
It wasn't believable.
And now even some Republican groups are making
this a focus.
Let's talk about that next